allez vous faire [ __ ]
[Musique]
homelander qu'est-ce qui vous a décidé à vous
joindre à var chance d'utiliser mes dons pour
aider à rendre le monde meilleur,
pas comme ça peut sembler mauvais à
quiconque je ne suis pas un pédo au fait  je
n'ai même pas de doigts je ne suis pas un [ __ ] de pédo
benjamin
oh vous êtes vraiment nuls hein
[Musique]
l'idée est que l'extérieur vous
correspondra enfin à l'intérieur
vous imaginez le visage que vous voulez avoir
la vie que vous voulez avoir
il suffit de frotter ça sur tout ton visage
ici on va le
feu
[ __ ]
je comprends ta colère la violence n'est
jamais la réponse [ __ ] ta
gueule  shitballs
kill me
[Musique]
james frenchy qu'as-tu mis dans ce
truc
toi